[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم بلا نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
ترفضه تبادلا مراسل جورنال قبل محاكمته
وصحيفه
تنفي اتهامات التجسس
خلال لقائه المبعوثه للاممي امين مجلس
التعاون يؤكد دعم الجهود الامميه لحل
الازمه في اليمن
معدل البطاله بين السعوديين يسجلوا
انخفاضا الى ثمانيه في الربع الاخير من
في الرابعه
رابعات تتجول حصريا داخل حدائق الملك عبد
الله في الرياض وترصد اخر الاعمال
الانشائيه
والارصاد السعوديه تنفي للرابعه دقه
الانباء حول موجه برد قاسيه تؤثر على عده
مناطق
قرارات محكمه روسيه احتجاز مراسل وول
ستريت جورنال الصحفي ايفان جريشكو فيتش
لمده شهرين على ذمه التحق التحقيق بتهمه
التجسس وخلال محاكمته اكد مراسل ستريت
جورنال انه غير مذنب في التيامات التجسس
المواجهه اليه كما قال محاميه انه منع من
دخول قاعه المحكمه والاطلاع على الاتهامات
وكانت صحيفته
لمراسلها بالتجسس وطالبت بالافراج عنه
فورا ومن جهتها كدت روسيا ان تبادل مراسله
مع امريكا لن يحدث قبل محاكمته وصدور
الحكم الخارجيه الروسيه قالت ان اعتقال
المراسي المرتبط بالتجسس مشيره الى ان
مكان يفعله ليس له علاقه بالصحافه وقالت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
الزخاروبان مراسله
ضبط متلبسا وبالجرم المشهود اثناء تسريب
معلومات عن احدى المجمعات الصناعيه
العسكريه الروسيه
من موسكو تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه
مرحبا بك يبدو ان التطورات والتداعيات
تتصاعد في قضيه حتى الان ما هي اخر
التحديثات
مرحبا خالد بالفعل اليوم جلسه المحاكمه
التي عقدت اليوم كانت قد افضت الى اعتقال
المراسل مراسل الى مده شهرين وتم منع دخول
محاميه الخاص وتعيين محامي له من قبل
محامي تابع للحكومه الروسيه طبعا كانت قد
تحدثت الخارجيه الروسيه انه من المبكر
الان حديث عن امكانيه حدوث عمليه تبادل
لسجناء بين روسيا وبين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كانت ايضا قد علق الكرملين على
هذه الاعتقال وقال ان انه تم اعتقال
الصحفي متلبثا بعد طبعا توجهه الى مدينه
معلومات عن مجمع صناعي عسكري وهذا ما يدرج
تحت
اسرار الدوله في روسيا طبعا بالنسبه الى
الخارجيه الروسيه كانت ايضا قد علقت على
ان هناك العديد من الصحافيين الذين يعملون
تحت غطاء الصحافه ولكن يقومون بجمع
معلومات
لارسالها الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كما حدث اليوم والاتهامات التي وجهت الى
هذا الصحفي اليوم خالد من هو
هذا يعني من معلومات متوفره عن
جنسيته الاصليه اين كان يعمل قبل
يعني هل من معلومات اكثر تفصيلا حول شخصيه
هو من مواليد عام 1991 عائلته هي تعود الى
حقبه الاتحاد السوفيتي التي هاجرت الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن ثم هو عاد
الى موسكو للعمل كصحفي عام 2017 عمل لعده
صحافه صحافه هنا كان عمل لموسكت ثم عمل
كما تحدثت طبعا وسائل الاعلام ايضا انه
كان يقوم بنشر
مقالات تحليليه وايضا تحقيقيه وبالاخص تخص
العمليه الخاصه التي بداتها روسيا في
اوكرانيا طبعا كما تعلم خالد هناك بعد بدء
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا في
روسيا تم صدور او سن الكثير من القوانين
التي طبعا
تخص عمل الصحافيين في روسيا وبالتالي كانت
تتحدث عن اي عن ان اي معلومات تخص العمليه
العسكريه بالاخص الجيش الروسي والتي لا
تتطابق طبعا مع المعلومات الرسميه
الحكوميه كانت وجه اصابع اتهام طبعا فورا
للشخص الذي يقوم بنشر هذه المعلومات او
بالتالي ممكن سجنه او تغريمه بمبالغ كبيره
في روسيا من الطبيعي ان يمنع تعيين محامي
خاص لمتهم في مثل هذه الحالات الاتيه
هو كما ذكرت لك تم منع محاميه الخاصه كما
تحدث المحامي من الدخول الى جلسه المحاكمه
ولكن حتى الان لا نعلم سبب منعه من الدخول
الى هذه الجلسه وبالتالي نحن بانتظار في
حال ستصدر او سيكون هناك جلسات محاكمه
اخرى جديده في الايام المقلده لنعلم او
نحصل على تفاصيل اكثر حول ما هي عدم او
منعه من الدخول الى جلسه المحاكمه خالد
شكرا جزيلا لك كيكه طعم مراسله العربيه من
موسكو
فدى نائب وزير الخرجات الروسي
سيرجيو ستواصل حاطه واشنطن بتجاربها
الصاروخيه وفقا لاتفاقيه
1988 واكد ايضا على ان حجم الولايات
المتحده معلومات عن تجاربها الصاروخيه
ينسف معاهده
يذكر ان الاداره الامريكيه قالت في وقت
سابق انها ستحجب عن روسيا بعض البيانات عن
قوتها النوويه واصفه ذلك بانه رد على
تعليق موسكو مشاركتها في معاهده الاسلحه
النوويه
مقدارنت وزاره دفاع الصينيه عن استعدادها
للعمل مع الجيش الروسي وذلك من اجل تعزيز
الاتصال والتنسيق الاستراتيجي بين البلدين
واضاف المتحدث باسم الوزاره ان الصداقه
بين الصين وروسيا تزداد قوه يوما بعد يوم
وان العلاقات الثنائيه ليست تحالفا سياسيا
عسكريا من حقبه الحرب البارده بل تتجاوز
هذا النموذج من العلاقات بين الدول
نشر الجيش الاوكراني مقطعا مصورا لتدمير
مخزن للذخيره والمعدات العسكريه الروسيه
في باخموت
القى ملك بريطانيا تشارلز الثالث كلمه في
البرلمان الالماني تتراقى خلالها
للتهديدات المحيطه باوروبا وبالوضع في
اوكرانيا واشار الى ان امن اوروبا مهدد
والقيم الديمقراطيه في اختبار صعب واكد
تشارلز الثالث على انه يجب الدفاع عن
اوكرانيا وقيم السلام والحريه كما ضاف
العايل البريطاني بان بلاده تتعاون مع
المانيا لتلبيه حاجه اوكرانيا من الاسلحه
تقدمت دول اوروبيه مجاوره لاوكرانيا بشكوى
الى المفوضيه الاوروبيه ضد ما تشهده
اسواقها من منافسه للمنتجات الزراعيه
الاوكرانيه
وتتميز هذه المنتجات بارتفاع حجم الانتاج
وانخفاض كلفتها مقارنه مع كلفه الانتاج في
الاسواق الاوروبيه التي تعرضت لخسائر
ماليه كبيره دفعت الى الموافقه على خطه
دعم مالي من بينها رصد مبلغ 56 مليون
لمساعده المزارعين في بولندا
اكدت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجات
الصينيه ماونينج ان بلادها ترحب بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه كشريك في الحوار مع
منظمه شانجا للتعاون وهي على استعداد
لتعزيز التعاون داخل المنظم
في الحوار مع منظمه شنغهاي للتعاون نحن
على استعداد لتعزيز التعاون مع السعوديه
في اطار منظمه شنغهاي للتعاون وتقديم
مساهمات اكبر للحفاظ على الامن والاستقرار
الاقليميين وكذلك المساهمه في التنميه
المتبادله
استقبل الامير العام لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي جاسم البديوي مبعوث الامم المتحده
الى اليمن هانس جراند بيرج في مقر الامانه
بالرياض اجرى خلال اللقاء تاكيد مجلس
التعاون على الدعم الجهود الامميه
المساهمه في تحقيق الامن والاستقرار
والتنميه في اليمن وذلك خلال التوصل او من
خلال التوصل الى حل سياسي للازمه اليمنيه
وفقا للمرجعيات الثلاث
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
معدل البطاله بين السعوديين يسجلن انخفاظا
بي الى 8% في الربع الاخير من 2022
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت هيئه الاحصاء
السعوديه انخفاض معدل البطاله الاجمالي او
الاجمالي السكان خلال الربع الاخير من
العام الماضي الى 4.8
وذلك مقارنه مع الربع الثالث من العام
ومدفوعا بالانشطه الحكوميه وكذلك دور
القطاع الخاص في عمليات التوظيف متجاوزا
التوقعات كما كشفت الهيئه عن انخفاض
البطاله بين السعوديين الى ثمانيه في
المئه مقارنه ب 9.9% في الربع الثالث من
عام 2022
الهيئه قالت في تقريرها الصادر اليوم بان
الانخفاض ياتي نتيجه لتشريعات وبرامج خاصه
بالتوطين ودعم الوظائف ومتابعه المنشات
من الرياض والكاتب الصحفي المختص في
الموارد البشريه محمد الطفيل استاذ محمد
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابع نحن امام
ربما رقم غير مسبوق بتسجيل هذا المعدل في
الانخفاض في معدلات البطاله بين السعوديه
كيف حدث او كيف وصلنا الى هذا الرقم اليوم
اولا اهنئ القياده فعليا على هذا الرقم
الذي يعدل اول تاريخيا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لان يصل الى هذا الرقم والذي
لم يعد او لم يكن بعيدا عن الرقم الذي
استهدفته الرؤيه وهو سبعه فاصله سبعه في
المئه من انخفاض البطاله في عام 2030 يوم
في الربع الرابع من 20 22 يؤكد انه تم
تحقيق الهدف بنسبه عاليه وهذا يدل على عده
اشياء اولا حسن التخطيط الاستراتيجي من
القياده السعوديه من خلال الرؤيه 20 30
العمل على ان يكون هناك اليه عمل واضحه من
قبل الوزارات المعنيه بما في ذلك الموارد
البشريه الى جانب القطاع الخاص والقطاع
الحكومي في التخفيف من حده البطاله في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واستخدام عدد
مبادرات النوعيه التي عملت عليها وزاره
الموارد البشريه منذ وقت كبير جدا فيما
يتعلق بالتوطين الى جانب ايضا حمايه
الاجور والاستثمار في راس المال البشري في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه كل هذه الامور
حققت فعليا نتائج مذهله الى جانب ايضا ما
حققت المملكه العربيه السعوديه من تطور
كبير في قطاع الاستثماري على سبيل المثال
فيما يتعلق باستثمار الخارجي داخل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تطوير منظومه العمل
اصلاح
التشريعات فيما يتعلق بالعمل داخل
السعوديه ضمان حقوق الموظفين والموظفات
والعاملين والعاملات سواء كان من القداع
السعودي غير السعوديين تحسين بيئه العمل
تحسين جوده الحياه العمل كل هذه الامور
اسهمت بشكل فعال في تحقيق كل مستهدفات
القياده في خفض هذه النسبه بشكل عالي جدا
جيد
هذا الرقم يجعلنا نقترب من المعدلات
الطبيعيه
من اربع الى سبعه تقريبا هي المعدلات
الطبيعيه النسبه البطاله فبالتالي متى
اولا يمكن ان نصل الى هذا الرقم عندما نصل
الى سبعه في المئه كمعدل البطاله في
المملكه
واما ما هي المرحله التاليه بعد ذلك
اعتقد خالد انه المملكه حققت الرقم يعني
تتكلم عن ثمانيه في في عشرين او في الربع
الرابع من 20 22 المستهدف عندك سبعه في
عشرين ثلاثين فاعتقد السنه القادمه باذن
الله اذا كان مسار الاقتصاد السعودي بهذا
المسار ومسار العمل السعودي بهذا الطريقه
سنحقق المستهدف 2030 قبل
الهدف باكثر من ثلاث سنوات او اربع سنوات
وبالتالي اليوم انت جالس تحقق المستهدف
الحقيقي لبرنامج الرؤيه 2030 في نسبه
البطاله ما بعد ذلك ستعمل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه على الحفاظ على هذا الرقم وايضا
خفض بشكل اكثر وتفعيل ايضا قرارات حديثه
يمكن ان تقلل من هذه النسبه ورفع مستوى
ايضا جوده الحياه في سوق العمل السعودي ثم
نعرف انه المرحله المقبله يعني سيتجه
الامر الى العمل على رفع الوظائف الجيده
من 50 الى 80% بدلا اقصد بالوظائف الجيده
اولا الاستاذ محمد في هذا الموضوع المملكه
قادمه على مشاريع حديثه جدا ورائده فيما
يتعلق بمشاريع الرؤيه الى جانب ايضا تطور
كثير من
مجالات الحياه في كل القطاعات ليس فقط في
قطاع التقنيه بل اصبحت كل القطاعات تعتمد
بشكل كبير على الذكاء الاصطناعي الى جانب
ايضا جوده العمل وايضا العمل على
استراتيجيات وبرامج واهداف وكل هذه الامور
تتطلب رفع مستوى الموظفين الى اعلى مستوى
في الهدف من ذلك الوظائف الجيده هو رفع
مستوى كادر التوظيف والموظفين بشكل عام من
ادنى وظيفه الى اعلى وظيفه لان تحقق كل
مناحي الحياه اليوم يمكن تاهيل الموظف
للقيام بعده اعمال في نفس المستوى وفي نفس
اللحظه بالاضافه الى القيام على تطوير
الموظف في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي تطوير
الموظف في مجال التقني تطوير الموظف في
الجانب المعرفي استثمار راس المال البشري
في المبتكرين والمبتكرات تفعيل ايضا دور
الموظفين المتميزين قادرين على العطاء
بالاضافه الى رفع مستوى
الجانب المعرفي لديهم في كل ما يتعلق
بالاقتصاد المعرفي لتحقيق مجتمع متميز
ونوعي في سوق العمل يمكن ان يحقق ايرادات
واستثمار عالي جدا في هذه الكوادر بما
يحقق ايضا ايرادات للدوله نفسه والمؤسسات
والمنظمات
النسبه والتناسب بين معدلات البطاله عند
النساء والرجال يمكن اعتقد الرقم اقل عند
النساء مكرره بالرجال الاستاذ محمد صحح
هذه المعلومه يمكن حقق الربط لما تتكلم عن
النسبه مقارنه للعدد الكلي اعتقد ان نسبه
التوظ يف في النساء عاليه جدا مقارنه
بالعدد الكلي او الاجمالي في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لاسيما ايضا وجود
[موسيقى]
في مكه المكرمه تعمل قوات الطوارئ الخاصه
برئاسه امن الدوله باداره وتنظيم الحشود
داخل ساحات المسجد الحرام طوال ايام شهر
رمضان لضمان سلامتي وانسيابيه دخولي وخروج
المعتمرين والمصلين والزوار والتقديم
الخدمات الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
طوق امني لقوات الطوارئ الخاصه بالعاصمه
المقدسه داخل ساحات المسجد الحرام لضبط
عمليه تدفقات البشريه للمعتمرين والمصلين
والزوار بعد تشغيل الحرم المكي بكامل
الطاقه الاستيعابيه بموسم رمضان هذا العام
سخرت قطاعاتها كافه امكانياتها البشريه
والاليه بالاضافه الى جاهزيتها وجاهزيه
جميع الوحدات لخدمه ضيوف الرحمن هذه
الخدمه التي نتشرف بها كما تشرف بها جميع
القطاعات الامنيه والخدميه في خدمه ضيوف
الرحمن اداره الحشود وحمايتها هي المهمه
الاولى لهؤلاء الرجال الذين يقفون جنبا
الى جنب لتنظيم وتفكيك الكثافات البشريه
وتقديم الخدمات الانسانيه قوات الخاصه
برئاسه امن الدوله احد قطاعات رئاسه الامن
الدوله المشاركه في هذه المهمه وتقوم
باداره الحشود البشريه في الساحه الجنوبيه
من المسجد الحرام اضافه الى توفير الحمايه
الامنيه لملوك ورؤساء الدول اثناء اداء
مناسك العمره بالاضافه الى جاهزيه وحداتها
الخاصه للقيام بالمهام النوعيه وقت الحاجه
والدعم والاسناد في اي موقف او حدث يشهد
الحرم المكي منذ بدايه شهر رمضان اعدادا
ضخمه من المعتمرين والمصلين مما ضاعف
اعمال رجال الامن بمختلف القطاعات لحفظ
سلامه وامن الزائرين ومسانده القطاعات
العامله من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي
العربيه
يعد مشروع توسعه السعوديه الثالثه نقله
نوعيه في تاريخ المسجد الحرام بمساحه
اجماليه تصل الى قرابه المليون متر مربع
وتتسع لاكثر من 900 الف مصلن وقد شملت
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه 4 منارات وعددا
من القباب المتحركه والثابته باكثر من
اثنتين
اجواء رمضانيه مميزه تعيشها محافظه حوطه
بني تميم لما تتميز به من تاريخ عريق
وعادات اجتماعيه اصله ايضا تتميز الحوطه
بالمائده الرمضانيه الغنيه وبلاكلات
التراثيه عبد الرحمن
[موسيقى]
من امامي قلعه الامام تركي بن عبد الله
تاريخيه بمركز الحلوه في محافظه حوطه بني
تميم التاريخ هنا ممتد لالاف السنين وشهر
رمضان المبارك له نكهته الخاصه والمميزه
[موسيقى]
الامام تركي بن عبد الله مؤسس الدوله
السعوديه الثانيه صلى في هذا المسجد
التاريخي قبل اكثر من 200 عام يمثل هذا
المسجد قيمه تاريخيه كبيره هنا في مركز
الحلوه بمحافظه حوطه بني تميم ابو عبد
العزيز يام المصلين في هذا المسجد منذ
اكثر من 35 عاما بيئه المسجد اختلفت عن
الحين في رمضان تحديدا طبعا تختلف هو كنا
طال عمرك نصلي نصلي بن عبد الله بن خليفه
الله يرحمه سلم لنا عشرين
عشرين وبعد العشر الاولى نجلس في القهوه
وندخنهم ونطيبهم هم نعلق
العشره الاخيره تسوون فطور جماعي في
المسجد
مثلا البيت هذا مثل في عنده مثل مد والبيت
الثاني هذا عنده صعب خلاص بكره على البيت
نفطر
يجمعون نحطه
[موسيقى]
هذا البيت فيه كيلوين
المائده الرمضانيه في حوطه بني تميم غنيه
بالاكلات الشعبيه المميزه هذا القصام طال
عمرك هذا شغل البيت يا سلام
هذا فلفل هذا الفلفل احمر يقولون شجره
اكبر شوي
اشتاق كثيرا الى تفاصيل شهر رمضان اثناء
طفولتي بهذه الكلمات المليئه بالحنين
يتحدث مساعد الحسين عن عاداتي شهر رمضان
قديمه السحور نتسحر مع الله حالنا ونستمع
معهم والان استمعنا طال عمرك واذن صلاه
الفجر رحنا ونصينا المسجد وصلينا طال عمرك
وعودنا نقرا القران
يعني كان اول يعني مشددين عليه لازم تقرا
القران لازم تختمر في رمضان ولازم نختمه
هذه عاده لا بد منها وكان فيه بعد تشييع
من الوالدين
وتشجيع من الاهل الثاني طال عمرك انهم
طالعوك يقول اللي يحفظ القران ولا لا
وعلى يد واحده
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من حوطه بني تميم
العربيه
طلب مستمره ايضا فيها بعد قليل
الارصاد السعوديه في دقه الانباء حول موجه
برد قاسيه تؤثر على عده مناطق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نتابع مباشره الان معكم
الصوره الان كما هو معتاد في الرابع من
الحرم المكي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
نصفيان يعني مرحبا بك هاني حديثنا اكثر عن
هذه التوسعه التوسعه الثالثه كيف اثرت على
حركه المعتمرين والزوار في الحرم المكي
الشريف
نعم اهلا بك خالد واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه طبعا بالفعل التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه هي تعتبر نقلا نوعيه في تاريخ
المسجد الحرام كون ان هذه التوسعه التي
تصل مساحتها الى اكثر من مليون متر مربع
وتتسع لاكثر من 900 الف مصلي حتى هذه
اللحظه طبعا هي المشاريع في يعني في
مراحلها الاخيره ونحن نتواجد الان من خلال
كاميرتال العربيه التي ترصد الكاميرا
الداخليه من بوابه رقم 100 وهي بوابه
الملك عبد الله في التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه وكذلك الكاميرا التي نشاهدها الان
وهي ترصد
الساحات الخارجيه
للتوسعه السعوديه الثالثه طبعا التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه
ناهيك عن المساحه وايضا عن عدد المصلين
ولكن ايضا عمليه الطراز تم اخذه في عمليه
التصميم وكذلك عمليه المعمار وايضا اتساع
الابواب حيث يتوفر في هذه التوسعه فقط 80
بابا لدخول المصلين كل باب يتسع عرضه الى
اكثر من 20 متر يعني نتحدث بالفعل عن اكثر
من 210 ابواب على المسجد الحرام في مكه
المكرمه 80 بابا فقط في التوسعه الحاليه
التي يشاهد وهذه الصور الان نشاهد
الارتفاع الشاهق لاحد ابواب التوسعه
الجديده في باب في التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه في الحرم المكي وفي المسجد الحرام
طبعا هناك ايضا من العمليات الاخرى او
التنفيذات الاخرى
بجانب الحفاظ على سير المعتمرين او الحجاج
في موسم الحج عمليه تنظيم الامني وكذلك
ارشاد المعتمرين او الزائر للمسجد لاماكن
موصلياتهم ايضا هناك لا ننسى الخدمات
الذكيه والتطبيقات الذكيه التي وفرتها
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين هنا هنا نتحدث اليوم
عن اكثر من عشرين تطبيقا موفرا داخل ارجاء
مسجد الحرام بامكان المصلين او الزوار ان
يستعينوا بهذه التطبيقات واحده من هذه
التطبيقات هي تطبيق في كيفيه عمليه وصولهم
من باب الى اخر خاصه نحن نتحدث اليوم عن
المساحه كبرى داخل المسجد الحرام ايضا من
ضمن التطبيقات في كيفيه الاستعانه
بالعربات المتحركه والعربات الكهربائيه
والتي اصبحت الان
متناولا سهل بالنسبه للمعتمرين وزوار
المسجد الحرام وايضا هناك تطبيقات
لارشاديه ودعويه تحث المعتمرين وايضا توضح
لهم النسك او الركن الصحيح بالنسبه
للاعتبار او كذلك في موسم الحج طبعا هناك
مشاريع ولو نتجول قليلا ونقوم بالدخول الى
داخل هذه التوسعه نحن فقط نقف عند باب
الملك عبد الله وهو باب رقم 100 في
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه ولكن بالفعل
عندما نقوم بالدخول الى داخل الممرات
وداخل اماكن التي تتجه
للمصليات المخصصه للرجال والنساء نشاهد
الساعه والاتساع الكبير والساحه الكبيره
بالنسبه لحركه المعتمرين وهذا ما اخذ في
عين الاعتبار اثناء عمليه تصميم
المسجد او التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه بحيث
يكون عمليه متاحه طبعا احد العربات ايضا
الان التي يقوم احد الموظفين هنا المختصين
بماء زمزم يقوم بنقلها الى احد اركان
التوسعه وهي ايضا من العمليات
المستمره التي تنفذها رئاسه شؤون الحرب
بين هذا القسم هو قسم خاص بتنظيم
ومصليات النساء وايضا يوجد عليه ايضا
تنظيما امنيا وايضا عمليه امنيه حتى تكون
العمليه سلسه داخل التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه او ايضا داخل المسجد الحرام بشكل
كامل شكرا جزيلا لك اذا نصفي المراسل
العربيه من الحرم المكي الشيخ
وفي غرب العاصمه السعوديه الرياض تسارعت
اعمال وبناء مشروع حدائق الملك عبد الله
العالميه الممتده على مساحه تقارب
المليونين
و580 الف متر مربع وتجاوزت نسبه انجاز
الاعمال الانشائيه والبنى التحتيه للمشروع
الضخم 40% منذ عام 2019 وذلك خلال عمل
امانه الرياض على مواءمه اهداف المشروع من
مستهدفات رؤيه 2030 في مجالات السياحه
والترفيه والتعليم والبيئه
ونشاهد معكم الان صوره ايضا من حدائق
الملك عبد الله العالميه ينضم الينا من
هناك مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز
حياك الله نواف كيف ترصد او تشاهد حجم
الانجاز الان في حدائق الملك عبد الله
نعم خالد مرحله متقدمه وصل لها مشروع
حدائق الملك كعبد الله العالميه هذا
المشروع الضخم الذي بدا العقد التنفيذي له
في عام 2019 عندما عملت امانه منطقه
الرياض على مواءمه هذا المشروع مع
مستهدفات رؤيه 2030 سياحيا وبيئيا
واقتصاديا وايضا حتى ترفيهيا من خلال هذا
المشروع متبقي يعني اكثر من النصف قليلا
او اقل ايضا نسبه الانجاز تجاوزت الاربعين
بالمئه اعمال البنى التحتيه توشك على
الانتهاء لانشاءات مستمره حقيقه المشروع
يسير بوتيره سريعه في هذه الاوقات واقف
الان انا امام مبنى الهلالين وهو واحد من
المباني الرئيسيه او العناصر المهمه في
المشروع والذي يضم سبع حدائق تمثل الحقب
التاريخيه القديمه
في العالم بالاضافه الى العديد من المواقع
الاخرى من خلف الان حديقه الوادي الممتده
على مساحه 100000 متر مربع وهي تمثل
الثروه البيئيه للسعوديه وتركز على ذلك
العديد من المواقع والمنشات الاخرى في
المشروع مثل الحدائق الخارجيه التي تركز
على التعليم تفاصيل اكثر معي الان مدير
المشروع المهندس ناصر الوادعي اهلا وسهلا
مهندس ناصر في البدايه 40% نسبه متقدمه
تجاوز طموها في هذا المشروع ما هي تفاصيل
الانجازات التي تمت خلال الفتره الماضيه
بحمد الله وتوفيقه ودعمنا للقياده الرشيده
ومتابعه من القيادات بامانه منطقه الرياض
وعلى راسهم
امين منطقه الرياض الحمد لله تجاوزت نسبه
الاعمال الاربعين في المئه نستطيع ان نلخص
المحاور الانجاز في ثلاثه محاور المحور
الرئيسي مبنى الهلالين والمتحف النباتي تم
انجاز معظم
الخرسانيه واعمال العزل واعمال الهيكل
المعدني بالاضافه الى التغطيه الخاصه بهذا
المبنى
كما تم الانجاز الاعمال الشبكات البنيه
التحتيه للري
والتصريف المحور الاخر البنيه التحتيه
للموقع العام لخدمات المسانده الحمد لله
تم انجاز نسبه كبيره من الاعمال الشبكات
الميكانيكيه بما فيها تصريف مياه الامطار
شبكات الري المعالجه مياه الشرب بالاضافه
الى الشبكات الجهد المتوسط والجهد المنخفض
المحور الاخير الحدائق كما تفضلتم الحدائق
الخارجيه وهي تتمثل في حدائق الطيور
والفراشات الاكتشاف الصوت والضوء معظم
الاعمال في هذه الحداث الاساسيه انتهت بما
فيها الشبكات والجاسات الحجريه المتبقي ان
شاء الله اعمال التشطيبات خلال الفتره
القادمه مهندس ناصر يعني لاحظنا في
المشروع وفي تفاصيل المشروع بالاضافه الى
التركيز على السياحه والترفيه وايضا
الثقافه وغيرها هناك تركيز مهم على قطاع
التعليم كيف سيضيف هذا المشروع الى قطاع
التعليم من خلال المنظومه التعليميه في
السعوديه طبعا حنا نستهدف في المشروع ان
يكون بيئه جاذبه
التعليم على مستويه المستوى الاول المستوى
البحث العلمي والتعليم العالي الاستفاده
من الاصول اللي موجوده سواء بتنوع
النباتات اكثر من 1400 نوع من النباتات
بامكان الاجراءات العلميه بالاضافه الى
التعليم العام عمل الزيارات الميدانيه
للطلاب المدارس لنشر الوعي في المحافظه
على البيئه والمحافظه على ثروه الطبيعيه
البيئيه المملكه داخل مبنى الهلاليين يوجد
سبع حدائق او متحف ان استطعنا القول بانه
هذا المتحف يختلف عن بقيه المتاحف
النباتيه في دول العالم كيف ذلك صحيح
المتحف
تم تصميمه بشكل مختلف عن المتاحف النباتيه
الموجوده حول العالم بحيث يحكي قصه
النباتات من مختلف الحقب التاريخيه فيها
النبات ابتداء من العصر الديفوني وصولا
الى العصر الحديث جميع
المتاحف الموجوده تم تاصيل النباتات بشكل
علمي يمكن طبعا للزائر الانتقال فيها بشكل
سلس
بوجود بعض الانظمه والاجهزه التي تشكل
الطقس والبيئه التي عاشت فيها النباتات في
تلك الحقبه كل الشكر لك مهندس ناصر اذا في
هذا المشروع الذي سيكون معلم مهم من معالم
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وهو يقع بالقرب
من مشروع الجديه احدى اكبر واهم المشاريع
الترفيهيه والرياضيه في السعوديه وهو تابع
لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه سيكون هذا
المشروع مهم وايضا
معززا للاقتصاد السعودي والسياحه في
السعوديه ضمن خطط رؤيه 2030 شكرا جزيلا لك
من الملك عبد الله العالميه مراسل العربيه
نواف عزيز
حدائق الملك عبد الله العالميه
تمتد على مساحه مليونين متر مربع
وتتميز بمبنى على شكله هلالين وتضم حدائق
مائيه وحدائق طبيعيه
كما تضم مسارات للمشي ومطاعم
وتحتوي على ساحه احتفالات وفعاليه
[موسيقى]
دعت وزاره التجاره السعوديه اصحاب المتاجر
الالكترونيه الى توثيق متاجرهم في منصه
الاعمال التابعه للمركز السعودي للاعمال
بدلا من منصه معروف التجاره السعوديه
اوضحت بان الانتقال لمنصه الاعمال جاء
للتطوير اجراءات التوثيق وتعزيز الموثوقيه
في التعاملات الماليه بما يقلل من عمليات
النصب والاحتيال تشهد السعوديه نموا
ملحوظا في زراعه البن وتسعى الى جعل 13
محافظه في الجزء الجنوبي الغربي من البلاد
مصدرا لانتاج البن ورفع نسبه انتاجي دعمنا
الاقتصاد الوطني
البني السعودي ومستقبل زراعته مع زميل
العنود العبدلي
كشفت دراسه حديثه عن تجاوز انفاق
السعوديين على القهوه سنويا المليار ريال
وهو ما جعل السعوديه ضمن اكثر 10 دول حول
العالم استهلاكا للبن باكثر من 80 الف طن
سنويا حيث تقدر مشاهدينا الكميات
المستورده بالاسواق السعوديه من البن ما
بين 70 الى تسعين الف طن سنويا وعليه تسعى
السعوديه لتحقيق الاكتفاء الذاتي من
الناتج المحلي مستقبلا ورفع الناتج المحلي
غير النفطي وذلك عبر انشاء 60 مزرعه
نموذجيه للبن لتعزيز الامن الغذائي في
المناطق الريفيه وزياده الانتاج الزراعي
كما تسعى السعوديه مشاهدينا الى جعل 13
محافظه في الجزء الجنوبي الغربي من البلاد
مصدرا مهما لانتاج البن خصوصا البن
الخولاني للتميز جودته ووفق دراسات حديثه
فان السعوديه شهدت نموا سنويا لاستهلاك
القهوه بنحو اربعه في المئه بين عام
2021 فيما يتوقع لقطاع زراعه البن في
السعوديه نموا بنسبه خمسه في المئه خلال
سنوات المقبله ليصل الى نحو 29 الف طن في
نهايه 20 سته وعشرين ما يتيح ويخلق فرصا
استثماريه جاذبه في القطاع ووفقا لاخر
الاحصائيات مشاهدينا فقط تجاوز الناتج
المحلي من البني في المحافظات الجبليه
بمناطق جازان والباحه وعسير الف
الفئه طن سنويا ونحو 350 طن من البن
الصافي بعد التقشير كما بلغ عدد مزارع
الوان مشاهدين فيها اكثر من
2500 مزرعه واحتوت على نحو 400 الف شجره
في السعوديه ايضا في مركز الارصادر
العربيه دقه ما يتم تداوله بشان موجه برد
قاسيه وانخفاض حاد في درجات الحراره
ستشهدها عده مناطق وكان مرصد الارصاد كشف
في تقرير له قبل يومين عن تقلبات جويه
منها وطول امطار غزيره ومتوسطه على معظم
المناطق حتى الاثنين المقبل
[موسيقى]
الشهر الرابع من شهور السنه الميلاديه
يسمى بابريل وهو احد الاربعه شهور الذي
يتكون من ثلاثين يوما يسمى بالعراق وبلاد
شام بنيسان وهي كلمه سومريه تعني الباكوره
اي انه ياتي في باكوره الربيع ومعتقهر
الزمن اصبح ياتي في عز الربيع ويتزامن ذلك
مع موسم صياح النبات وابريل كلمه مشتقه من
اللاتينيه
والتي تعني التفتح فهو موسم تتفتح فيه
جميع انواع النباتات ومطره منبت للربيع
الصيفي وهل الاولين الله يرحمهم بالشام
يقولون مطرت نيسان بتحيا الارض
والانسان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والامطار الساقطه في شهر ابريل يسميها اهل
الخليج بس الرايات والحجاز بالروائح واهل
نجد بلراويح والباديه يسمونها بسماك نسبه
الى نجيب اسماك لا تسقني ماء الحياه بذله
بل فسقني بالعزي كاس الحنظلي ان كنت في
عدد العبيد فهمتي فوق الثريا والسماك
الاعزلي
[موسيقى]
ترفض تبادل مراسل قبل محاكمته وصحيفه تنفي
اتهامات التجسس
خلال لقائه المبعوثه الاممي ابن مجلس
التعاون يؤكد دعم الجهود الامميه لحل
الازمه في اليمن
وعدل البطاله بين السعوديين يسجلوا
انخفاضا الى 8% في الربع الاخير من 2022
الرابعه تتجول حصريا داخل حدائق الملك
عبدالله في الرياض وترصد اخر الاعمال
الانشائيه
والارصاد السعوديه في دقه الانباء حول
موجه برد قاسيه تؤثر على عده مناطق
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]